we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day i got a phone call
yesterday from someone pointing out that
there is a way to know whether the
michael cohen leaked tapes are real
there's this big debate going on some
people on the Trump side are now
starting to suggest that they think the
Michael Cohen leaked tapes might have
been doctored on the on the other hand
there have been forensic audio analysts
who have listened to the tapes who have
not found any evidence of the tapes
being doctored this is kind of funny
this is how a caller believes we know
the tapes are real hi Dave I heard some
people saying the Trump audio tapes are
not real this is how you know they're
real you can hear some saying give me a
coke multiple times through all of them
and also you laughed when he said that I
thought that was great
hello brother haven't heard from the
eggman for a little while but he is
still paying close attention to the show
yeah we were commenting about that here
in the studio like off the show just how
funny give me a coke thing was he isn't
it a known thing that Trump is sort of
like semi addicted to coke and he's
drinking cokes all the time I thought it
was Diet Coke I think the New York Times
ran a story on his dietary habit and
that was a big thing if I recall
correctly it was KFC the Taco bowl
salads from inside trunk to Trump Tower
and Diet Coke I just remember like
twelve diet cokes per day which is an
insane amount of well it's not sugar but
no aspartame would have a lot of
aspartame a lot of aspartame I would be
staying away from those diet cokes stay
away from the soda when is the last time
you had an old-fashioned soda Pat I like
the Mexican cokes along with the burrito
uh-huh but it's still been a little
while yeah oh boy all right well let's
cut that out when we edit the show we
don't want that getting out but no I
haven't had a coke for a really long
time I tend to only have coke when I am
in another country and it's sweetened
with actual sugar that's actually a
really good point and not the
high-fructose corn syrup and I think the
last coke I had was December 7th of 2009
when I was in Spain no I'm kidding it
was probably like three or four years
ago I just not into soda it's just not
my thing you know we should do a taste
test on the show if I can help your
friends buds have changed over time and
yeah you like it I'm evolving into a
something else I don't know okay we've
got a great bonus show for you today
Mike Pompeo
listed the conditions for talks with
Iran hours after Trump set there are no
preconditions clearly some kind of
disconnect is going on there we've
talked a little bit about terraforming
Mars NASA says it's not happening
anytime soon and we have also learned
that more than a thousand people have
downloaded plans that allow you to 3d
print and ar-15 rifle we've talked
before about the 3d printing of guns a
little bit been a while it's been a
while we're going to talk about it again
on the per on the bonus show today two
ways to access the bonus show become a
member at WWE at medCom
become a patron for at least 5 bucks a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show both ways support the show and get
you access to the world's famous bonus
show